okay so i'm going to talk about a
splitting necklaces and about a
non-constructive proofs and this is a
story about thieves
that steal together a necklace
but they are not just any thief they are
mathematically oriented
so imagine that we have two thieves
and they still together a necklace and
this necklace has a beads of two types
say let's say diamonds and rubies they
want to split the necklace evenly among
them and they want that each of them
will get the same number of diamonds and
also the same number of rubies so they
open the necklace it's a clasp and then
they have an interval of beads and the
necklace can be complicated but but this
is an example no pattern or intervals or
that's right we don't assume anything
let's assume for simplicity that the
number of diamonds and also the number
of rubies is even so that it is possible
to split it evenly among the two thieves
now they want to
minimize the number of cuts that they do
in the necklace what they want to do is
to cut the necklace in several places
this will split it into intervals of
speeds and then they will take the
intervals and will distribute it among
them and they won't in this example that
each of them will get four diamonds and
then three of the rubies all together
seven beats but it's important minimal
cuts it's not necessarily the minimum
possible number of cuts completely but
they want to have a small number of cuts
each of them should get seven beads so
we can try to cut the necklace in the
middle then we will have two intervals
of it the left part and the right part
but you see that in the left part we
have two few rubies only one and each of
them should get three so this doesn't
work what we can do is we can take this
interval of seven bits and shift it one
to the right and then so this
corresponds to having the cuts here and
here
and then in this interval we have two
rubies which is still too few but we are
making progress and then we can try to
shift it gradually and hope at some
point it will be okay if we shift it up
to this place here so
three and this one two three four so the
two cuts will be here and here
then in the middle interval we have
exactly four diamonds in three rubies
and therefore also we have four diamonds
and three rubies in what's left and this
means that two cuts are enough
now a claim that actually what we proved
here that two cuts are always enough and
why is this the case
because we started by splitting the
necklace so imagine now that it's a an
even maybe longer and very complicated
necklace with diamonds and rubies we
split it into two halves by cutting the
middle now if on the left cut there are
too few rubies then on the right cut
there will be too many right because all
together we have the right amount and
then we use what is called the discrete
version of the intermediate value
theorem so that's a theorem in
mathematics but these are just words
what this means
so we observe here that whenever we
shift
the interval here by one to the right
then the number of rubies in it can
change only by one because we lose one
bid and we gain one bit so we can gain
at most one ruby and therefore we
started maybe with too few rubies at the
end we have too many and every time we
change the number of them just by one so
that means it's somewhere in the middle
we must hit exactly the right number so
this means that two cuts always suffice
so the ruby number is only ever changing
by one so we have a firm control of that
that's right but the diamonds are taking
care of themselves as well yeah so
you're right say the diamonds will be
okay as well because the total number of
beads each one gets is the correct
number so once we have the right number
of rubies then the number of diamonds
will be will be correct as well we saw
also in this example but it's kind of
obvious that if all the diamonds appear
contiguously on the necklace somewhere
and all the rubies also appear
contiguously it is clear that the number
of cuts we need is at least two because
we have to have some cut in the middle
of the interval of diamonds and we have
to have some cart in the middle of the
interval of rubies so it means that
sometimes we need two cards and what we
just proved is that two cuts are always
sufficient sometimes we can get away
with one cut that's only when it's
symmetric or yeah so it doesn't have to
be symmetric but it means that exactly
in the left side we have the correct
number of rubies so it's true sometimes
one cut is enough but what we proved
about two cuts is that two cuts are
always enough so now we can try to make
it a little bit more complicated and
let's say that still the number of types
of beads is sealed to only diamonds and
rubies but now we have instead of two
thieves we have four thieves you know
sometimes it's better to have a bigger
group so so we have four of them a small
gang of thieves and they still are
mathematically oriented still they want
to split it evenly
and still they are lucky in the number
of diamonds and also the number of
rubies is divisible by four how many
cuts do they need now we have this
necklace which is an interval of beads
by what we saw before we can have two
cuts maybe here and here
so that in this interval and in those
two together we have the correct number
of rubies and the correct number of
diamonds we split it into two
fair shares okay and now
we can take this interval that contains
a half that went to two of the thieves
we started with four of them they split
themselves into two groups of two
thieves and then once these two thiefs
got the fair share that they deserve
then they use another two cuts in their
part in order to split it evenly among
the two of them in these two intervals
of the other two we can shift them to
somewhere let's say here in this
interval we put it here and we forget
that there are two intervals so we view
it again as an interval of beads and
again this other group of two additional
fields can cut this part in two places
and split it evenly among them so if we
go back to the original necklace this
corresponds to six cuts the two original
ones these two and these two okay so it
means with four
fifths in two
types six cuts are always enough and it
is good to observe that sometimes six
cuts are needed so again this simple
case where the diamonds appear
contiguously and afterwards the rubies
also appear contiguously if now we have
four thieves then of course we need at
least three cuts inside the interval of
the diamonds because we have to cut it
into four parts and we need at least
three cuts inside the interval of rubies
so all together in this example we need
six cuts what we showed is that six cuts
are always enough also four was very
convenient because you're able to use
what we learned from two
what about what if there were three
thieves right yeah so it's not much more
complicated let's leave it as an
exercise to to the viewers but it's not
much more complicated to seize that for
two types of beads with three then four
cuts will always be enough for a similar
reason to what we said before i mean
with an extra simple twist
and and sometimes we need four so so it
will be possible it's getting
significantly more complicated
when the number of types of beads
increases so maybe we can have diamonds
and sapphires and rubies and let's just
say the the general theorem let's say a
group of k
thieves we denote by t
the number of types of beads and again
they stole together this necklace it
contains beads of t different types the
number of beads of each type is
divisible by k they want to split it
among themselves and they want to do it
with a small number of cuts if we have
this example in which each type appears
contiguously so maybe all the diamonds
appear here and then they all say rubies
appear here and then also cepha emeralds
if they're green emeralds yeah emeralds
are better so they appear right here and
so on then it's clear that we need at
least k minus one cuts inside the
interval of each type so for ten fifths
we would need nine cuts inside each
interval and all together nine times t
cuts and in general we need in this
example
we need
k minus 1
times t cuts so it means sometimes k
minus 1 times t cuts are necessary and
the theorem says that k minus 1 times t
cuts always suffice there is always a
way to cut the necklace in k minus 1
times t places and then divide the
resulting intervals into k collections
and each collection will contain exactly
the same number of beads of each type so
this is more complicated and i'm not
going to describe the proof which uses
some tools from continuous mathematics
specifically from topology but let me
just say that
the first step is a simple step if we
know validity of this assertion of this
theorem for k
one fifths and t types and we know it
also for k two thiefs and p types then
it implies that it is true for k one
times k two thiefs and t types and this
is actually not difficult it's similar
to what we saw before when we dealt with
four thieves so for example if it is
true for a three
thiefs and it's true also for five
fifths then it will be true for 15.
if we know the statement were
three-fifths and for five and we want to
get it for 15
then the way to proceed is as follows
the 15 thieves split themselves into
three groups each of five thieves and
then we view each group as a super thief
and then we use the result for three and
we split it fairly among these three
super thieves and then
each group that corresponds to a to a
supersiv which consists of five normal
thieves they use the result for five
inside the group and then if we just
work out the numbers then it will give
us the correct statement so this is
simple but the more complicated thing is
that
the second step is to
kind of
change the problem into a continuous one
and i'm not describing how exactly
and then to use some theorem in topology
to get the result
for
the continuous problem that implies the
discrete version that we need and the
nice thing is that actually the
topological result
works only when the number of thieves is
a prime number is a number that is not
divisible by any other number besides
one in itself something about the nature
of that proof means it only works for
prime numbers that's right so it's kind
of lucky that we have this say way to
get the result for a three times five
from the result for three and the result
for five because the result for three
and four five we can get it using this
topology which seems to be necessary
when the number of types of beads is at
least three right we saw that with two
types of beads everything is simple but
with three or more types of beads and we
need this topology so any number of
thieves can be handled because any
number can be built from prime numbers
that's right any number is a can be
expressed even uniquely as a product of
primes and then we can use
this result a feature of these proofs
that i want to to mention that is
intriguing is the fact that it is
non-constructive the topological proof
does not provide any efficient procedure
or algorithm to solve the computational
problem so if for example the number of
thieves is five and the number of types
of beads is five so the number of cuts
needed will be four times five which is
twenty and the total number of beads
let's say is two hundred then
we can always check all possibilities we
know for sure that we can cut it in 20
places and divide the resulting
intervals evenly among the five thieves
and we can at least in principle check
all possibilities but even if we use all
the computers in the world for years and
years we will not be able to check all
possibilities the numbers are just too
big and somehow the proof does not
provide an efficient way to solve this
problem and moreover it is likely to
suspect that there is no such efficient
procedure
because it is known that this problem is
what is called complete
for some specific complexity class and
this means that there is a large number
of computational problems
and which we don't know to solve
efficiently any of them
and if we will be able to solve
efficiently
this specific problem then we will be
able to solve efficiently all of those
problems and because we do not know to
solve any of them then maybe it's likely
to believe that this is impossible and
that means from the thieves point of
view that maybe they thought that's a
challenging part is to get the necklace
but actually maybe the even more
challenging thing is to split it
afterwards evenly among them
all the computers in the world you know
the total number of elementary particles
in the universe is something like a 10
to the 80. and it's really easy to
formulate a very simple combinatorial
problem where the number of
possibilities will be more than 10 to 80
just because often
things grow exponentially in terms of
their parameters
much longer longer ago
where we think about a having labian
interval representing a cake
watch carefully only time in my life i'm
going to wash my hands
in diamonds